Jacqueline it is the Thanksgiving season
and there are movies that people either
watch during Thanksgiving or come out
during Thanksgiving but what should we
tell our viewers to go and watch during
this special turkey day well first I
just want to break down the idea that I
think a lot of people sometimes
Thanksgiving or the Christmas holiday is
the only time they actually get together
to go see movies so on I think like
going to the theater is a big part of it
but I love watching stuff at home and
one of my favorite films is this like
little hidden gem called home for the
holidays it was directed by Jodie Foster
it stars Holly Hunter Robert Downey jr.
before he got sober and it is the
perfect Thanksgiving film it is all
about the meal it is all about the
family dynamic and how sometimes that
meal getting everyone together is a
rough and tough thing I think it's the
perfect Thanksgiving to your point I
think that any movie you can go and sit
down whether it be a cartoon if you've
got young kids whether it be action or
drama just find something that's gonna
bring the family together I personally
like in my family the Eddie Murphy movie
so we'll watch Nutty Professor
we'll watch coming to America please
don't make any Africa jokes because I
know you want to and will also watch
Beverly Hills Cop one too and never but
I know there's some Thanksgiving Day
movies that you enjoy as well what are
they I like laughs with my family and
planes trains and automobiles hands down
my favorite Thanksgiving movie and down
our hands between two soft pillows those
aren't pillows
Steve Martin and that I like that you
picked that one again that's movie worth
Thanksgiving as part of the film and
another one I really love
scent of a woman in 88 precision
certified fresh in the tomato meter got
Al Pacino is Oscar I love that girl know
Al Pacino's great Chris O'Donnell is
actually really good in it well for me
it's simple because home alone is my
childhood really and the VAT came out
during the Thanksgiving Day season so I
love it Macaulay Culkin you know we talk
about TV too in the Detroit Lions play
and the Dallas Cowboys play there
there's so much good Thanksgiving TV I
like Cheers I mean seriously Shelley
Long in the pilgrim garb and they get
into this huge food fight at the end of
the episode is hilarious but one of my
actual favorites like Thanksgiving
episodes Brooklyn nine-nine they had a
great Thanksgiving episode where they
did Thanksgiving in the station I think
we're gonna go and say the pinnacle
though is gonna be the Charlie Brown
Thanksgiving that's every year animation
people stop no it's the Great Pumpkin
Charlie Brown
it's the Halloween round holiday that's
the best one the Great Pumpkin is the
best Charlie Brown it is not agree to
disagree and let's just go eat have a
happy Thanksgiving from all of us here
at see it skip it
[Music]